no one denies the term predestination no
one no one denies that it's by the power
of God that you live breathe and move
and have your being right hand means
right or what your power and hand had
determined what it's simply saying
is keep this in mind this is where the
calvinist get you oh see now read so
people know what we're talking about
read acts 42720 do you have it with you
you want me to read yeah yeah I got it
here for truly in the acts 4:27 for
truly in this city they there were
gathered together against your holy
servant Jesus whom you anointed both
Herod and Pontius Pilate along with the
Gentiles and the people of Israel to do
whatever your hand and your plan had
predestined to take place okay now hand
whatever your hand and what sorry
whatever your hand and your plan plan so
Hand means power strength the fact is
this is a fact according to scripture
anything I do good or bad is because God
is sustaining me if God doesn't sustain
me I can't exist right right so God's
hand means the very fact that you're
able to let's say rebel against God and
defy God is because God has given you
that very breath which You're Now using
to attack him because if not God could
wipe you out it's number
one number two when it says his plan yes
it's his plan that his son dies but does
that mean God has to then create them in
such a way where he compels them to do
the very thing against Jesus because
they're going to tell you well they were
not forced to sin they freely sin but
they're making my point because the
calvinist will tell you God didn't make
them kill Jesus they did it naturally
because of their fall nature they're
actually than arguing my case why
because what they saying is
predestination does not mean God forc
them to sin by killing Christ because
they wanted to kill him and what God is
allow them to kill Christ well that's
not Calvinism that's our position what
is our position without time God knowing
that if I send the son at this time in
this period of history and he shows
himself to this group that group will
want to kill him therefore since the Sun
dies in our place for our sin the sun
will come at that very time that God
knows that these people will carry out
their desires to kill him that's all
it's saying so you're saying that
because God is omniscient he knows and
he willingly uh um entered creation to
die he chose that specific time in order
to fulfill his plan and you know how I
know that because Galatians 4:4 says in
the fullness of time in the fullness of
time God sent forth his son one of born
under the law okay so they'll even admit
see because I know what they say wait so
are you saying God made them kill Jesus
say no no no they killed him freely
because they're acting on their sinful
nature because even a calvinist will
tell you Sinners sin because they want
to God doesn't make them sin but then if
you ask them could they' have chosen not
to do that sin God didn't predestinate
they'll say no he had to do that sin
even though he did it freely okay so
this is where I catch them so you're
agreeing with me God didn't force them
to sin They carried out the desires of
their heart now God could have stopped
them but instead he allowed them to
that's what it means by his hand because
if he wanted he could have stopped them
the fact he didn't stop that means that
even in that evil act he's still
sustaining them just like he sustains
everything right right but they'll admit
to you if you ask them right question so
did God make them kill Jesus no no no no
they killed him out of their own sinful
heart God doesn't need to make them sin
because sin comes naturally to them so
they naturally and freely wanted to kill
Jesus and God allowed them to do that
all right say okay hold on so you're
admitting to me God didn't have to make
them kill Jesus for them to end up
Killing Jesus no all God had to do was
remove his restraint and allow them to
act on their desires yes that's my
position my position is God knowing that
if the son was sent at this time these
people would hate him to the point of
wanting to kill him and since the son
came to die he came at the time that he
knew that this is what they want and
allowed them to carry it out but he
didn't force them to do it he didn't
predestin to do in the sense that H I'm
going to create them to want to kill my
son and I'm going to create them that
they'll want a desire to kill my son so
that it will be something they desire
and
act so I don't have to compel them to do
it because they're already created with
that desire and then all I need to do is
let them act on that desire but then if
you ask them well what if they chose not
to could they have chose not to do no no
no they were predestined that's not my
position that's their position you
understand the
difference let me repeat the difference
our position says
God knowing that if the sun comes at
this time these group of individuals
will hate him to the point that they'll
want to kill him not that he created
them to want to kill him and act upon it
he know if if he appears at this time
they'll want to kill him and now I
either can stop them from killing him or
allow it okay because they're in my hand
in my
control but since it's my plan for the
son to die for the son to die therefore
this is the time he'll come because
these individuals will want to kill him
and all I need to do is allow them to
kill him that Jesus told Judas you who
have followed me including Judas you who
have followed me will sit on 12 Thrones
judging the 12 tribes of Israel and
Judas is one of the 12 this is in
Matthew 19:28 was Jesus lying to
Judas I Jesus would never lie but he
told the 12 and Judas is one of 12 you
who followed me will sit on 12 Thrones
judging Israel so what is Jesus telling
Judas that he wants him to betray him
and go to hell or does he want Judas to
follow him so he can reign with him it
sounds like the lad it sounds like he
wants to you better believe here let me
show the verse again you better Sor
making you go through this again it's
okay it's okay they again I know these
because I was a calvinist when you take
off the calvinist lenses then what
you're seeing is not God creating people
to commit the sin that he wants them to
commit but God knowing that if he
creates this person he's going to want
to commit the sin and he allows them to
do it see the difference Calum says God
created you to commit the sin he wants
you to commit this position that know
God knows that if he created you you're
going to want to do this sin and then he
can either allow you to do it or prevent
you okay okay now watch look at the
promise Matthew 1928 Jesus said to them
truly I say to you in the New World when
the son of man shall sit on his glorious
Throne it's new heaven new Earth you
have followed me will also sit on 12
Thrones judging the 12 tribes of Israel
the only 12 Apostles included Judas at
this time but notice what Jesus says in
the new heaven new Earth where I ran on
my Throne you you who follow me will
reign with me on 12 Thrones judging
Israel so does Jesus really want Judas
to live and reign with him in the new
heaven new Earth that's what it that's
what it sounds like yeah but according
to your calvinist buddy no he already
created him to betray Christ so he can
go to hell right but then we have a
conflict either God is lying or God is
schizophrenic has two Wills because
that's what some Calvinists will say God
has two Wills what he decrees and what
he desires so though Jesus desired Judas
to reign with him he had determined that
he would betray him and go to
hell this is Calvinism for you okay now
watch another promise Look what Jesus
says and Judas is one of them he's there
the they're all there the 12 and the 70
all the disciples are present as the 70
come back talking about how they cast
out demons now watch this Luke 101 17-
20 Luke 10:1 17-
20 watch here ready the 70 now the 12
are with Jesus so they're there they're
listening the 70 returned with Joy
saying Lord even the demons are subject
to us in your name and he said to them I
saw Satan fall like lightning from
Heaven behold I have given you Authority
now is he talking to some or all of them
all of them and in Matthew 10 ver8 when
Jesus sent out the 12 Judas being one of
them he gave Judas the power to cast out
demons and raise the dead in Matthew 10
veres 1 to8 and I'll show it to you but
here he's on all of them I've given you
all right here with me Judas is there
Authority right to tread upon serpents
and scorpions and over all the power of
the enemy and nothing shall hurt you
nevertheless do not rejoice in this that
the spirits are subject to you some of
you or all of you standing there did he
qualify by saying some no all of them
right all of them but Rejoice that your
names are written in heaven judas's name
is written in heaven
how what do you mean how he says it that
all of you your names are written in
heaven okay but but isn't he a terrible
you know didn't he commit one of the
worst sins ever but you still don't get
it that shows that God's desire was
Judas I want you to live that's why I've
written your name in heaven but now that
you betray me I'm G to blot your name
out oh that's what Jesus says whoever
endures to the end
his name I will not blot out Revelation
3:5 so what if you don't
endure then he then the name is is taken
away right there so Judas your name is
there so what does this show you about
God's desire for Judas that God desires
Judas to actually be with the TW in
heaven yeah you got it now final one let
me prove to you that Jesus even died for
Judas are you
ready okay right here now watch this pay
attention because he doesn't qualify do
say some of you most of you but not all
of you and he took bread Luke 22
19-23 and when he had given thanks he
broke it and gave it to them saying this
is my body which is given for you do
this in remembrance of me and likewise
this cup after supper likewise the cup
after supper saying this cup which is
poured out for you is a New Covenant of
my blood now did he say some of you most
of you or all of you right here all of
them right there clearly oh wait he just
said I'm breaking my body and shedding
my blood for you but now notice who's
there behold the hand of him who betrays
me is with me on the
table so Judas is there so he Judas just
heard Jesus saying this bread is my body
broken for you you too Judas this cup is
my blood shed for you you too Judas but
look even though I'm going to die for
Judas he's still going to betray
me look at the travesty and the Betrayal
that I love him to the point to die for
him to save him and how does he respond
betraying me now here's where they're
going to try to get you but here's where
I'm going to bury them for the son of
man goes as it has been determined say
predestined but go to that man by whom
he is betrayed and they began to
question one another which of them it
was that would do this again does it
mean that because Christ was determined
to be betrayed that means god also
created Judas to make him betray or does
it mean that God knew that if Jesus
comes at that time one of his disciples
would betray him in order to bring about
Jesus's
death one of his disciples would betray
him in order to bring about Jesus's
death because it's predestined for
Christ to die but that doesn't mean that
the actors involved were created to
carry out those sins otherwise right
they would have no CH choice to the
contrary because it was predestin that's
not if you read the Bible and as a whole
God predestines based on for knowledge
without time God knows at this time at
this place all of these individuals they
will Harbor these feelings towards Jesus
and one of his disciples will betray him
and this actually shows you how Majestic
God is that he's so infinitely wise and
Brilliant he even knows the perfect time
where all of things will come together
to bring about Christ's death without
having to create them and make them do
it h yeah glory to God yeah it's not
that Judas was created to betray Christ
and he had no choice it's that God knew
that if the Lord went at that time one
of those who'd Fallen would be Judas and
Judas would be so full of the devil that
he'd betray him and then the others to
whom he betrays him would want to kill
him so it's all going to work out that
this is the perfect time for for my son
to die for your
sin
okay that's all yeah I think a lot of
that is cleared up in in
um God pre or determining Things based
on his OMS his forn knowledge of time
that that clears up so many of those
issues that I guess you're you're faced
with when kind of bringing Calvinism to
its necessary that's where you get
blinded in fact here let me prove to you
that the word forn knowledge is used
with predestination so it's for
knowledge and predestination acts
223 that's also by Jesus being betrayed
because I thought that to you would you
like me would you like me to read this
yeah if you can read out loud for me
this Jesus delivered up according to the
definite plan and forn knowledge of God
you crucified so how did God
plan based on knowledge fourge read it
again so people can see read this Jesus
delivered up according to the definite
plan and forn knowledge of God so his
plan was based on what the forn
knowledge forn knowledge is not for
ordaining don't let them lie to you okay
yeah so he planned and determined based
on what for knowledge there you go
that's why I'm no longer a calvinist